today we're talking about a new cloud
region open source security protocol and
a cloud logging update
i'm jenny brown and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
digital tools like cloud computing are
fueling economic transformation across
the u.s for example google's investment
in cities and communities across ohio is
bringing over 200 jobs to the state and
is helping provide almost 13 billion
dollars of economic activity for tens of
thousands of ohio businesses
and to accelerate that transformation we
are thrilled to announce the newest
google cloud region in columbus the
columbus cloud region is open and brings
a second region to the midwest the 10th
region in north america and grows our
global cloud region count to 33.
we believe that psp can provide a number
of significant security benefits for the
industry
given its proven track record in our
production environment we hope that it
can become a standard for scalable
secure communication across a wide range
of settings and applications to support
this we are making psp open source to
encourage broader adoption by the
community check out the blog for more
info we are thrilled to announce the
release of a new update to the cloud
logging library for node.js with the key
new features of improved error handling
and writing structured logging to
standard output which is handy if you
run applications in serverless
environments like google functions
head to the blog post for a full list of
details
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us and we'll see it in the
cloud
you